[Music]
the more nurture you have the more
nature you need to have it and this is
the game changer it's also what's
incredibly frightening modify the
genomes of twin girls in china implanted
them
and these babies have now been born we
don't speak gene well enough to write
really dangerous stuff yet in 10 years
we've solved the genome we've got the
structure of dna we've solved the
genetic program how it works
[Music]
and it's the regulation of these genes
that's much more complex in humans that
we're trying to understand
so to understand genes you have to
understand dna dna is of course the
molecule whose structure was elucidated
by jim watson and francis crick it forms
a double helix and what does dna stand
for i spoke to a school last week and um
i was advised to tell them that it stood
for do not ask
but it actually stands for
deoxyribonucleic acid um it's a very
long thin molecule we every cell of our
body has two meters of it
and um it lies in every nucleus of our
cell and it's made up of three billion
bases which is the alphabet of dna and
there's only four bases within within
that
alphabet so genes are like genes lie on
within dna like beads on a string
and they're made up of different
combinations of bases
so all the genes and the intervening dna
we don't often we don't know what it
does it's called the genome and you'll
hear a lot about the genome and that's
what we talk about when we say we're
going to sequence the genome
so the genome actually is broken up into
23 chromosomes so 23 different rods um
we also thought of dna encoding rna
which encodes protein that was the
central dogma and protein is what gives
us our eye color and so on um
we now know there are genes that make
rna and they don't make proteins these
non-coding rnas are very important for
regulating genes and you'll probably
hear more about this
when you hear about epigenetics
but ultimately it's the gene that
determines what goes on downstream
or another fact is that
genes we've inherited one gene from our
mother and one from our father
and genes can differ subtly between
individuals because of the slightly
different bases and these are term
mutation a lot of these are term
mutations
some of these mutations can lead to
disease and others can have a more
subtle effect on our appearance or
behavior and often that's cumulative and
when you hear about the complexity it's
that complexity of multiple genes acting
together that is very hard to work out
but we are starting to work it out
um
so the point of the genome was project
was to understand the sequence of the
three billion bases that made up dna and
then find out where the genes lay and
later studies have looked into regions
of dna that actually regulate genes so
the genome project surprises us all but
by showing us that we only have about as
many genes as a fruit fly
or or a worm that sydney brenner was
working on
and it's the regulation of these genes
that's much more complex in humans that
we're trying to understand also only
three percent of our dna actually codes
for genes three percent is known to be
regulatory we don't know what the rest
is
um that was called junk dna but but it
may not be junk um as sydney brenda said
you take out you throw away the trash
but you put the junk in the attic
so you know you want to know what we
still don't know exactly what that junk
does but i think it does something
um
so it's also only during disease and
aging that we see alterations in the
epigenome and you'll hear about that so
epigenetic changes are not heritable
usually and they're modified after birth
due to the environment or genetically
programmed and it's the gene that sets
up both the epigenetic alterations and
the
morphogenetic fields you you said that
the genes
um they determine what happens
downstream are you saying basically that
the causality goes to the gene and
everything else that happens flows from
the gene from the if we use an up down
metaphor from the bottom up is
there are you can have modifications to
the dna itself
through environment for example so there
can be modifications that way and that's
what you'll hear about with epigenetics
but it's still the gene that has been
modified
inherited dna differences is the major
systematic influence making us who we
are as individuals
you say genes and people think of
hard-wired puppeteers making us do
things you know
deterministic and
part of that's because we learn about
genetics from mendel and mendel if you
remember did experiments with pea plants
and he was essentially studying single
gene mutations in pea plants if you were
a pea plant you'd like your seeds to be
nice and round and smooth there's a
mutation a single gene mutation
that causes them to be wrinkled
so
that these single gene mutations are
deterministic and hardwired and
necessary and sufficient for humans
there are maybe seven eight thousand
single gene disorders most of them
thankfully are very rare
but if you had one of these like on the
tip of chromosome 4 and we have 23 pairs
of chromosomes the tip of chromosome 4
has a gene that if if
if you receive the inherit of the
mutated version of it you have
huntington's disease which is a
neurological degeneration that happens
later in life and if you have that
mutation you will die from huntington's
it doesn't matter what your environment
is your exercise regime your food it
will kill you it's necessary and
sufficient
[Music]
and so those are very important for the
people who get them but what we've
learned in the last decade is that
that's not where
most of the genetic influence comes from
for complex traits like those who study
in psychology and common disorders like
in medicine heart disease obesity
diabetes for example there's strong
genetic influence but there's no
evidence for major gene effects that is
any one bit of dna is making a huge
difference what it's about this
heritability
is about
thousands of tiny dna differences
that together
have an impact on a disorder
so that's a whole new ball game you know
single gene genetics would be rather
simple you just find the gene you find
out what it does wrong and you try to
change it although we're not very good
at doing those things but here
we've got thousands of little dna
differences that are making you
predispose say to schizophrenia
or in my case to obesity
and
it's a it makes it go from a
deterministic hard-wired single gene
concept
to a probabilistic
propensity
and that's what's hard for people to
understand
when you say twin studies people
actually mean a much more common
experiment where you have identical
twins a third of all to inverse one
percent of all bursts are twinned a
third of those are identical twins which
are monozygotic clones of one another
they have the same dna the other group
though are fraternal twins and it's like
a biological experiment these are
both sets of twins are born in the same
womb raised in the same family but one
group identical twins are twice as
similar genetically so if a trait like
say body mass index is heritable you'd
have to predict identical twins or more
similar than non-identical twins
there's also an adoption method which is
important because it's completely
different it's a social experiment where
kids who are adopted away at birth are
followed with their adoptive parents so
you've got parents who share nurture but
not nature with their kids the adoptive
parents and you have parents who share
heredity nature but not nurture with
their adopted away offspring so just
taking body mass index to make this
concrete to people the correlation for
identical twins for body mass index is
about point um seven five and four
non-identical twins is about point three
five so it's maybe just to explain that
the correlation that means it's 75 of it
is genetic as nature and 25 nurture for
the identical twins about individual
differences in a population and so it's
saying identical twins are more similar
than non-identical twins they both share
environment so their similarity could be
due to environment but if it's genetic
you'd expect the identical twins to be
much more similar than fraternal twins
because identical twins are 100 similar
genetically paternal twins 50
so with that difference you can estimate
that the heritability that is the extent
to which inherited dna differences
account for differences in bmi body mass
index is about 70 percent which people
find shocking if you ask your audience
how heritable is it they'd estimate
about 30 so it's twice as heritable as
they think but what's really neat is the
adoption method
complete converges on that i did your
parents and children correlate about
0.35 for body mass index
it could be nature or nurture for a
century people assumed it's nurture
makes sense families provide the food
and style lifestyles and exercise
but children adopted away from their
birth parents at birth never seeing them
again correlate 0.35 the same with their
birth parents
adopted children
their correlation with their adoptive
parents who rear them
for body mass index is zero
wow an example of where what's running
in families is nature genetics not
nurture but the environment's important
what's really impressive about identical
is reared apart is you know they're
raised in uncorrelated environments and
they're very very similar
inherited dna differences is the major
systematic influence making us who we
are as individuals but it's the best
evidence we have for the importance of
the environment however the environment
doesn't work the way we thought it
worked from freud onwards it's not
nurture in the sense of systematic
family environmental influences it's
something else and we don't really know
what that something else is but after 30
years of trying to find this something
else i've come to conclude
these are idiosyncratic stochastic
chance sorts of events it's not that
they're unimportant it's just that we
don't have control over them and it's
important for parents to know that they
have much less control over their
children's ultimate outcome than they
think
first because
genetics is the major systematic force
secondly the environmental influences
aren't the levers that they can control
professors are inclined to attribute the
intelligence their children to nature
and of their students to nurture
so the idea that nature and nurture are
alternatives
poisoned a lot of debates in the 20th
century and i hope it doesn't have to
poison debate in the 21st because it is
not a zero-sum thing it's not a spectrum
from one to the other and it's not one
as an alternative to another
indeed as william james said right at
the start of the debate and i think i
wish we'd listen to this more the more
nurture you have the more nature you
need to have it and vice versa
here's an example monkeys are not
innately afraid of snakes
a monkey born in the lab showing a snake
for the first time is not frightened of
it but it's much easier to teach a
monkey fear of snakes than to teach it
fear of flowers and this was the result
of a brilliant experiment by susan
minnicker in which she dubbed a video so
that the monkey saw another monkey being
frightened of a snake but actually she'd
put a flower over the snake on the video
so the monkey thought the other monkey
was terrified of flowers and all it
learnt was that some monkeys are bonkers
the more we lift the lid on jeans the
more we find that they are actually open
to experience they take their cues from
what happens to us
if you remember this talk that i'm
giving right now
it will be because inside your brain
cells
genes are being switched on and off for
fractions of a second to alter the
strength of connections between nerve
cells to lay down a new new memory
that's what genes are actually doing
they're often
literally turning on and off during our
lifetimes and they're at the mercy of
what happens to us
so nurture can be fate and nature can be
malleable
and as marianne said the idea that the
left believes in nurture while the right
believes in nature i think he's just
plain empirically wrong if you look at
what people actually do
because the left believes in tapping
talent among underprivileged people
finding the bright kid and giving her
opportunity and that only makes sense if
you believe there are such things as
bright kids
whereas the right only believes in edu
where the right believes in education
and that only makes sense if you think
nurture is necessary as well as nature
or to put it more bluntly as someone
said to me professors are inclined to
attribute the intelligence of their
children to nature and of their students
to nurture
by doing that the dna gets repaired
introduces the change and voila you have
an edited gene
crispr allows for what's called gene
editing and gene editing is this new
version of genetic engineering
that's quite inexpensive
easy to use and very specific in how it
works
so up until now most genetic engineering
techniques have resulted for example in
huge swaths of dna being changed in the
process of making a genetic change
crispr has been a likened to like
genetic scissors in that you can go into
the dna of of literally any little
living thing
and change it to the very
single base base pair of the code of dna
that this is pretty this is significant
this is big and we're seeing crispr
emerge in all sorts of places whether
it's huma healthcare whether it's
industry agriculture we're also seeing
it starting to merge in places where
generally genetic engineering would have
been cross-prohibitive or too difficult
places like public health and
environmental conservation
and the way that it works because i
think this is important just i need to
i'm going to give you a quick science
lesson so we can all be on the same page
and then you can go to your next dinner
party and just really blow everyone's
mind
um
but basically crispr is so easy to use
because it really only requires two
components
one is this little blue guy which is
called the guide rna so the guide rna is
going to be a specific sequence that can
recognize whatever sequence of the dna
that you're trying to change so if that
sequence of the dna perhaps has
the single base change that causes
sickle cell disease you would create the
sequence that recognizes that to go to
that mutation and want to change it and
so the guide rna localizes the place of
dna that you want to change and this
which looks much different in real life
under microscopes is an enzyme called
cas9 and what this does is it cuts dna
this is an absolute nightmare for any
cell when its dna is cut it wants to
repair it immediately
and so what you can do is you can kind
of usurp that dna repair process by
introducing a dna template of whatever
you want to introduce into this genetic
sequence it could be changing the
sequence it could be adding an entirely
new sequence it could be removing
sequence from the dna and by doing that
the dna gets repaired introduces the
change and voila you have an edited gene
obviously it's a little bit more
complicated than this but this is sort
of
really how it works and this is what's
this is what's become so revolutionary
in the genetic engineering space
as i mentioned the ease of use of this
has allowed it to be entering into
totally new ways of solution-making or
things that we previously would have
been thinking it couldn't be
effective for agriculture is one i think
we can all kind of jump to the quick
conclusion of what this is looking at
this is thinking about using this for
genetically engineered crops thinking
about using this to remove certain pests
environmental conservation is another
so for example people are discussing
could we use crispr gene editing to give
coral
different kinds of genetic sequences
that make them resilient to warming sea
temperatures
could we use crispr gene editing to
suppress the emerald ash borer by
introducing sterility into that
population in north america and saving
the ash tree the other places this being
explored is within the public health
space so there's discussions around can
we use crispr gene editing
to suppress the malaria species the
malaria carrying species of mosquito so
this is some big these are really big
ideas and it's and it's not
it's not fully theoretical anymore i
think that's important that we all
understand sort of the status of where
this is and the one that i want everyone
to also be aware of is this project
that's funded by the gates foundation
this is a initiative called target
malaria
and they are using crispr gene editing
to create a spe a line of mosquitoes
that when released into the wild would
suppress the mosquito population that
carries malaria and hoping to save human
life and they do this because not only
does crispr allow you to make really
easy gene edits
in any living thing it's also allowed
for the production of what's called a
crispr based gene drive because if you
think about it if anyone remembers their
natural bio their biology training from
way back when things work through
natural selection right so if you're
going to release a mosquito that has
some gene on it that you want to push
through a species population
it's going to go mate with a wild
mosquito there's going to be only 50
inheritance of those genes and
eventually through natural selection
it's quite likely that mosquito would
get pushed out of the population and you
wouldn't really change
anything what a gene drive does is this
gene dry mosquito not only expresses the
gene edit that you want so say it's to
push sterility through this mosquito
population to suppress the population
it also expresses all the tools the
crispr
so the cast 9 the garden iron a the
stuff that we talked about on that
previous slide so that it makes those
very same edits in the wild gene that it
inherits
from from its wild parent so this gene
drive mosquito is going to mate with the
wild wild parent the child it inherits
the gene edited gene from the gene dry
appearance as well as the crispr to then
edit the same gene in the wild parent
and through that you get 100 of
inheritance of a gene and over time
every single mosquito in a population
will have that gene edit that you
require and this is the game changer
this is what's both exciting because it
means you can transform populations of
of species if you're trying to try and
create a solution for something it's
also what's incredibly frightening
you can completely alter a natural wild
species by releasing just a few of these
gene drive mosquitoes
the dialogue about what this means for
humanity was happening at the same time
this uh technology now
which we can
is revolutionary in its ability to allow
us to modify genomes of things of
interest like mice or or cells or
whatever it is
and was not born of someone trying to
find a new technology with which to
modify genomes it was born from the work
of people who were just investigating
what bacteria did and and it was through
that that essentially they understood
more about it and then they established
oh look these bacteria have this
mechanism it's to protect themselves
from viruses how does that work how well
it look it it has this thing and it can
oh look that means it could be
programmed and if you can program it you
can you know it's a tool and then
and
it's been really interesting actually
because
this was at least you know i'm still
relatively young so i don't know if this
is common or not but i don't think it is
so much namely in the same time at which
we started discussing this technology
and saying wow look at what we can now
achieve in the lab
the dialogue about what this means for
humanity
right was happening at the same time so
it was
found from interest developed as a tool
for modifying the genomes of mice that
we use to model human diseases and then
of course uh last year last january the
headlines broke that somebody in china
had actually used this technology to
modify the genomes of twin girls in
china implanted them um and these babies
have now been born
and i feel like that's a little case in
point of the whole scientific process
and the sort of worries that we have
because on one hand this person did that
and on the other hand scientists like me
have a really great tool with which we
can do better experiments now
and and yeah i mean i think luke's
totally right and
education is clearly key and regulation
is clearly somewhere very important in
this because
you know individuals can do it that the
case in china was an individual i mean
but does that mean that everybody else
should be deprived of something that is
good in their hands
we now effectively have a typewriter for
gene language
crispr cast nine is an example where we
got lucky because crispr cast nine
showed up at a point we now effectively
have a typewriter for gene language but
we don't have a rosetta stone for it so
the point is we are held back because we
don't speak gene well enough to write
really dangerous stuff yet we will
ultimately but we don't
so we now get time to deal with the
frightening prospect without having that
power at our disposal
each child born into the world is a
unique
untested genetic experiment
do we think that it is ethically
permissible to conduct
untested genetic experiments creating a
child with a genetic disorder
because that essentially is what sexual
reproduction is i mean each child born
into the world is a unique uh untested
genetic experiment um one doesn't know
what is going to happen um and in the
course of a lifetime that child will
probably undergo all all kinds of
suffering and eventually die
from old age or one of the diseases of
old age so personally i'm an
anti-natalist however the future does
not belong to anti-natalists it belongs
to fanatical life lovers and i think
that if one does believe it is ethically
justifiable to create new life
then one has an ethical obligation to
maximize the opportunity for one's child
or children to flourish
and so as a transhumanist i would
support
universal access to pre-implantation
genetic screening and counseling for all
prospective parents
yes that may involve artificial wounds
but
natural wounds too
because as molecular biology teases out
the genetic basis of pain misery
suffering pain
pain thresholds essentially yes it's
going to be able we're going to be able
to replace today's genetic crapshoot
with something more civilized
already we have the first uh crisper
babies in china unfortunately uh
rather than uh essentially improving the
well-being of the children in question
it was really a kind of experiment
nominally to
essentially protect the children from
hiv
in practice in animal models the genetic
mutation in question
actually enhances cognition the rogue
scientists was probably trying to create
smart babies but but my my my point here
is that yeah something like pain
sensitivity for example there is a
so-called volume knob for pain the scn9a
gene and if if if one thinks that
justified will have a child one can
choose the approximate pain uh threshold
pain sensitivity of your futurist child
raging from nonsense mutations no pain
at all to high to they low pain
thresholds um and so
just to conclude yes i very much uh hope
that we can move uh to a society of
truly planned parenthood in which all
babies are to use this rather
unfortunate label designer babies rather
than these untested genetic experiments
that we have now
nature has designed this in such a way
that we adjust to the unexpected
the notion that we are already
on the way
to eugenics in the traditional sense i
object to that strongly
and there are all kinds of reasons to
object to it first of all to begin to
manipulate
the information that is passed between
generations the information
that leads to the generation of our
species and begin to interfere with the
diversity
in mind that's simply wrong and first of
all because
for us to continue to adjust to the
world we live in
you know nature has designed this in
such a way that we adjust to the
unexpected
and today we cannot predict
what's going to happen tomorrow
if you're going to eradicate certain
aspects of homo sapiens through what
you guys call eugenics
make absolutely sure you know what
you're doing
imagine if rather than a newton or an
einstein every century we had many of
them in every generation
as a libertarian myself i think there's
been much too much emphasis on the
libertarian aspects of the debates
surrounding designer babies because then
you get concerned of the world drifting
towards something
what i'd like to do is emphasize a few
points about the communitarian and
egalitarian benefits
of designing babies that may make an
argument for running toward it rather
than being concerned that we're drifting
toward it
first designer babies hold the promise
of making the world better even for
those who wish you the practice
imagine if rather than a newton or an
einstein every century we had many of
them in every generation how many
diseases might we cure with this
knowledge how many insoluble scientific
or social problems might we fix
however much shakespeare or edison might
benefit from their own accomplishments
the rest of us benefit too and then that
since a rising tide raises all ships
second designer babies hold the promise
of creating a more equitable society
this may seem counterintuitive to a lot
of people but at present we already
grant considerable advantage to those
who are well healed um if you can hire
an academic tutor you can get into a
fenced university if you can hire a
tennis coach for your kids they can play
at wimbledon
and that compounds underlying biological
injustices
my sense is that everyone on this call
has a rather significant gift of
intelligence
having worked with patients whose iqs
are in the 75 to 80 range the world is
much harder for them we should make it
easier but that's also a significant
burden to bear
if we lived in a remotely equitable
world where there were any promise of us
reaching that point sometime soon there
might be a compelling argument for
limiting these sorts of reproductive
interventions but we don't
and with that in mind
designer babies may be the best
opportunity we have to create business
equality they might be the great
equalizer so my goal
with the underlying premise that these
are inevitable if you look at what
happened in china with germline editing
eventually somebody will begin designing
babies in the way that i am talking
about we want to make sure that
resources are devoted to making everyone
have an equal opportunity
and to making sure that the people who
don't reveal themselves this opportunity
have their rights protected
the problem with molecular biology is
not that it's mechanistic it's
crypto-vitalist
i don't have any problem with the genome
project i think it gives us
interesting and sometimes useful
information
i sent off for a 23andme 125 pound
sequencing i was hoping to announce the
results here for myself
unfortunately they take six weeks so i
can't so you know not against it but i
just think what we have is a problem of
enormous hype and a completely
unrealistic expectation of it
when i was an undergraduate at cambridge
in 1963
not quite as long ago as the model of
the heartbeat in 1960 um
i was
reading biochemistry and francis crick
and sydney brenner invited five or six
of us from the part two biochemistry
class to a series of evening seminars
they were grooming us to become
molecular biologists
um and basically they said you know in
ten years we've solved the genome we've
got the structure of dna we've solved
the genetic program how it works the the
um the coding
thing
and basically they said the unsolved
problems of biology are essentially
development and consciousness they
haven't been solved yet because the
people who have been working on them
were not molecular biologists nor were
they very clever they said but we're
going to solve them within 10 or 20
years and uh brenda said i'm taking
development and qrik said i'm taking
consciousness and they invited us to
join them
well i didn't i wasn't persuaded by them
about the power of this
but um
the
the exaggeration of the role of genes
the selfish gene idea for example a gene
for things with selfish replications
genetic programs these are all vitalist
fantasies in my opinion the problem with
molecular biology is not that it's
mechanistic it's crypto vitalist
and by attributing these you know
selfish properties to genes or programs
which uh intelligently designed by human
programmers i think of fantasies
projected onto genes
and i think they've led to an enormous
distortion of priorities in biology
i do have a slight vested interest here
because in 2009 i took part in a debate
with lewis walpurt
who's a leading uh materialist and
mechanist at cambridge at the science
festival on the nature of life and lewis
said um within his it won't be long
before given the genome of a of a baby
of a personalized egg we'll be able to
predict every detail of the ensuing
child
and i said louis i i how long do you
think that's going to take i said you
said soon i said what ten years well
well not ten years twenty no what well
maybe a century and i said well that's a
really really long time this is
promising
promissory materialism in an extreme
form i said can we have uh i said i bet
you uh that it won't be possible uh even
with a simpler organism within 20 years
and you said i'm sure it will so we have
a wager it was published in new
scientists the one thing we could easily
agree on was the stake we wanted
something to increase in value over 20
years rather than decrease like money so
it's a case of fine port we paid half
each
it's in the wine society vaults
and
so the wager is that by may the 1st 2029
walput said given the
fully sequenced genome of a fertilized
egg we'll be able to predict every
detail of not a human but at first he
said a chick
so i said okay lewis a chick so then he
rang me a week later and said well i've
discovered a chick it'd be a bit too
complicated i have to be a frog
and i said all right a frog
a chick or a frog
and then
after another week he rang me and he
said i i think even the frog's a bit too
complicated
it's going to have to be a nematode worm
um cena rep dieters and against and i
said well that's a big step down i said
if we're going to a millimeter long worm
then at least we should spell out that
to do this you've got to predict the
structure of every protein based on the
primary structure of the protein the
sequence of amino acids the threefold
folded up structure
and he got back to me about we said can
we just miss out the protein folding
thing
i understand there's a bit of a problem
predicting the tertiary structure of a
protein from the primary structure i
said yes there is i mean that's the
reason why this isn't going to work and
um so he he said well anyway um well
let's just uh leave it open
can it be any organism so the wager is
by 2029
it should be possible to predict on the
basis of the genome the structure of any
organism
any multicellular organism
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv
[Music]